welcome to my tutorial on how to make an
origami butterfly in this video I will
show you how to make the butterfly using
a regular sheet of printer paper if you
have origami paper that will work fine
also what we need to do is we need to
make the printer paper into a square so
we take this corner and we fold it down
on to this side until this edge here is
aligned with this edge make a crease and
you can cut off the excess paper now
that we have a piece of square paper
that has a diagonal fold in it going
this way we want to take this corner and
fold it down to this corner and try to
be as neat as possible so now if you
open up the paper you should have an X
in it now what we do is we take the
paper and we fold it in half going this
way by taking this edge and aligning it
with this edge and you make a crease so
now if you open it you should have an X
and a horizontal line once again fold it
on the horizontal line make sure it's
nice and flat now what we want to do is
we want to lift up this first layer here
and we want to tuck this corner in
towards the center of the model where my
thumb is lift up the first layer and you
tuck the corner in just like that
and then you fold and make good creases
do the same for the left side so lift up
the first sheet tuck the corner in and
then you make the creases again
so now you should have a model that
looks just like this and this is known
as the water bomb base or the paper
balloon base now that we have the proper
base to make the butterfly you should
notice that there are two top flaps and
two bottom flaps what we're going to do
is we're going to take both of the top
flaps and as you'll notice it has a
point here we want to put this point on
the top of the triangle and when we're
doing that this edge will align with
this outer edge of the triangle also so
point it to the top and then we can make
a crease so you should have something
that looks like this and we're going to
do the same with the other top flat and
make another crease so you should have
something that looks just like this now
we're going to flip the model over and
we're going to take the bottom of the
triangle and fold it towards the top but
we're not going to fold it all the way
up to the point we're going to leave a
little bit of overhang about the width
of your thumb so take the bottom fold it
towards the top just like that and leave
about a thumb width of overhang once you
have it around there then we're going to
crease the bottom of the model all the
way across so you should have something
that looks just like this now we're
going to flip the model over again and
now you should see that here are the
tips of the flaps which we previously
folded up towards the top now we're
going to bring them down just by pulling
on them like that when you do that
you'll see that it won't go down
because it is being held by this edge
here so what you have to do is just fold
it down and this edge should start to go
towards the center of the model when it
does just push down on it and then make
a good crease to flatten it out
and do the same with the left side bring
it down and just flatten out that hood
there just like that then we're going to
flip the model over again and this time
we're going to make the head so this is
going to be the head what we want to do
is we want to fold it all the way down
as far as it can go which is basically
on this edge here fold it down and make
a crease then we're going to fold it up
just a little bit so that there's a
little bit of overhang on the other side
so fold it up just about like that and
as you'll see there's a little bit
overhang on the other side so you should
have something that looks just like this
okay so we're pretty much done with the
butterfly we just have to fold the wings
and to do that what we're going to do is
we're going to take both halves of the
butterfly and fold them down away from
us so you want to fold the butterfly in
half this way and we're just going to
make a crease along this edge here okay
now what we want to do is if you'll see
there is an imaginary line from here to
here let me draw a line just so you
could see what I'm talking about
right along there where it leaves from
the bottom of the body here up to the
edge of the where the head was and what
you want to do is you want to fold
upwards along that line so fold the
wings upwards on that line and do the
same for the other side and then just
make creases along the base here on
these edges and then all you have to do
is you just want to fold you want to
fold these wings so that the edge of it
when you're folding it down is pretty
much in line with the top of the body so
if you look at it sideways it should
kind of be lined up with the body kind
of fold it straight down like that and
just make a crease along the wings and
then just pull on it a little bit and
there you go you are done with your
origami butterfly I hope you all enjoyed
my tutorial for making the origami
butterfly I'm also thinking of making a
tutorial for how to make an origami gift
box so if you've seen my tutorial for
how to make a paper ninja star where I
show you how to interlock the flaps of a
box and also how to interlock the flaps
of the ninja star that might come in
handy that way you can give someone a
personalized gift handmade by yourself
so thank you very much for watching and
don't forget to comment rate and
subscribe to my videos